[Music]
thank you very much for being with us
here at cloud next and specifically for
this IOT session with zebra and micro
edge our partners I know it's after
lunch and it's very crowded outside so
let me start with something real quick
yeah how many of you went to the
registration desk to get one of these
badges yesterday or this morning good
it's good to see everybody raising hands
I would be worried about our security so
when I went I was really excited because
behind the registration desk I saw this
whole Bank of zebra printers that were
printing these badges real time when we
came in and I was really excited because
that is actually the exact thing we're
here to talk about so we'll show you a
live demo with that printer and we have
zebra who is a leader in the printer
market globally and we have micro edge
who is a Google cloud technology partner
who enables these types of printers
these types of devices to get smart and
connected online really quickly and
securely so but that is the context so
we have the three speakers here i'm
vidya dalla I'm part of Google Cloud and
my focus and responsibility is on
developing the edge ecosystem around
Google Cloud IOT with that I just wanted
to talk a little bit about the role
Google play's in bringing this whole use
case to reality so if you think about
IOT the biggest technical challenge is
around the heterogeneous devices what I
mean by heterogeneous is devices come in
all sorts of shapes and colors compute
capability varies memory capability
varies cost form factor the environments
that these devices operate in as well
vary a lot and in connecting all of
these seamlessly reliably to the cloud
this is a problem that has not been
solved and this is where a partner like
micro edge comes in they are a Google
cloud technology partner and their stack
basically sits on
the devices add the edge what it does is
it makes the data collection and
injection process very seamless very
easy and very secure as Google Cloud we
see our role in making sure that the
infrastructure and the plumbing for
getting this data to the cloud is done
in a secure reliable and a scalable
manner but Micro Edge has a virtualized
environment that sits on the edge and
makes working with the operating systems
that operate on these devices much
easier so if you think about it micro
edge plus Google Cloud is what creates
the end-to-end platform that can be
deployed on a whole range of devices we
will talk about the handheld mobile
printer use case here but it can be
deployed on a whole range of devices in
a very very reliable manner which is a
big pain point in IOT today the last
thing I want to call out before I have
the next feature speaker come on stage
Victor salman's is is the fact that both
micro edge and Google cloud share a
fundamental philosophy about the usage
of the platform we want it to be no code
at most low code but low code also in an
in a modular way so that when developers
like yourselves are using this platform
you don't have to rewrite anything from
scratch that defeats the purpose of our
existence and the second thing is
security which is very much no
compromise in the IOT space the fastest
the single fastest way to have an IOT
project shelved is to have the risk of
negative PR or devices hacked so with
this technology and approach we work
with zebra together also are very
honored to have them as a partner for
Google Cloud to connect these printers
to make them online and real-time
interactive with that let me call
onstage
Victor salman's who heads up new product
development at zebras in their specialty
printer business who will talk us
through the whys and whys of this use
case and then Fred reward will talk us
through the how and the technological
detail that has gone into this we are
very happy to have you share your story
with us Victor thank you all right good
afternoon folks it's really a pleasure
to be here and talk with you about zebra
technologies we're gonna talk about
thermal printers thermal printers and
we're going to talk about our
partnership with micro edge so let's
start with printers printers you know
they're mission-critical devices that
live in our customers environments we
need to deliver labels receipts cards
when the customers wanted I mean these
are real-time embedded devices right
they're electromechanical really complex
devices right and they are constrained
right we know constrained devices in the
embedded world they're constrained by
their design they're constrained by the
cost we're always we're always trading
those off constrained by lifecycle we're
also constrained by that real time
component and what comes to mind is a
use case that we have we print at 12
inches per second and 400 micro seconds
is really really critical in that use
case so think about we have to get data
through the system format bitmaps make
bitmaps get them into a printhead and at
12 inches per second we're pumping 2,400
dots an eighth of a millimeter 2,400
dots an eighth of a millimeter every 400
microseconds that's that real kind time
constraint that we have to live under in
order to deliver on those
mission-critical applications for our
customers but you know in this day and
age we need to go faster all that
real-time stuff takes us time to develop
to make sure we get it right make sure
we get it right every single time so
imagine in this day and age where you
know things are moving so quickly IOT is
moving use-cases are changing
imagine if we could have a way to go
faster and develop applications on top
of that real time and keep them
separated keep them managed so that
we're delivering that real time but
we're able to go
faster faster and make those
applications I think we have solved that
with our Micro edge partnership so I'm
gonna tease you with that a little bit
and talk about it in a minute but first
I want to talk about zebra technologies
you see zebra technologies every day in
your day to day life you know we're
right there in front of you you know you
see us in retail helping you to purchase
that shirt or that your favorite dress
you see us with that delivery driver
getting that package to your doorstep
quickly and reliably you see us in
health care matching patients with
critical medications you get when your
car is returned through that rental car
we're there to get you fast through it
and get you to your terminal and last
but not least you see us in the NFL
that's right we're tracking and tracing
players in real time
that's zebra we're right there in front
of you and you know I'll just give you a
little bit of history
zebra celebrating 50 years as a
technology company this year and you
know we've been at it for 50 years you
know I heard recently that most
companies the average company lasts
about 15 years so we're real excited
about that we're a 4.2 billion dollar
company
we have over 7,000 employees throughout
the globe hmm
selling 180 countries about 95 percent
of the Fortune 500 companies but you
know we grew up with printers I've been
a printer guy for a long time we prove
up for printers but we are much much
more you know zebra is an end-to-end
solution company you know take a look at
all the components that we bring
together in order to solve our customer
unique needs workflow optimizations
productivity improvements all of it come
from this suite of products that build
on that solution from barcode printing
mobile computers scanners location
devices as I mentioned with the NFL
data platforms we have introduced a data
platform that aggregates all that data
it's powered by Google called savanna
aggregates all that IOT data in order so
that we can create solutions software
and solutions and our partners can also
create those solutions services and
supplies round out all of those ways
that we're solving solving problems for
our customers and you know the way that
we think about it is we sense what's
going on out on that edge analyze it and
act on it that is zebra technologies
we're not that printer company that we
grow up to be we're definitely that into
n solution company all right let's go
back to printers you know I've been
staring at this slide for for a while
and I am so proud of when I look at this
you know I think printers are a work of
art these mission-critical thermal
transfer thermal printers are really a
work of art and when you look at this
picture here we've built out this
powerful OS that kind of takes care of
that real time component like I
mentioned and on top of it we've built
all of these applications and at the end
of the day you kind of look at it we're
we're solving we're building this
horizontal solution set this ecosystem
in order to solve problems and help our
customers in four key verticals in
retail healthcare TNL and in
manufacturing you look at this and say
we are solving problems every day but
and I don't say but but and there are
still unique needs out there that our
customers demand there are new use cases
there are new application needs so what
have we done we created a custom
application group all of this internally
to build and solve those customer issues
but you know we and we solve those
problems every day you know from
standalone application emulations
integrations all of them with that
custom app
patient group they solve hundreds of
customer unique cases every year but
think of where there was a way that we
could open up this powerful engine that
we have here that we've built and make
it available to others make it available
to outside developers in order to go
faster and allow them to solve those
problems so that's where this unique
solution comes in with micro edge so
take a look at what this looks like and
imagine building a secure and that's the
most important part a secure Java based
application engine that sits on top of
all of that real-time stuff that zebra
will take care of so that you can go
fast or take an advantage of all of
those standard standard libraries that
exist in Java allows you to go faster
solve the unique problems more
efficiently and keep that keep that
real-time stuff and keep that
application stuff separated you know if
you step back and look at it it really
looks like that
app app revolution that you saw in the
mobile world coming into the embedded
printing world it's a very powerful
picture where we're enabling external
developers really three benefits we
external external developers to develop
these these new and unique use cases and
that we see them every day maybe web
browsing template printing that is
required that you can develop yourself
second it probably and it will help our
internal development I mentioned all
that work that goes on internally now we
can start to take advantage of the same
Java capabilities and build out those
those capabilities and some of them end
up in that kind of channel release that
I showed you on the previous slide and
third there's a third subtle one that
you see here you know you've got this
powerful engine that's sitting on the
edge performing on the edge let's give
it more responsibility
give it more respond
ability to take on take on some of the
hardware that's out there and get rid of
that hardware and let the printer do it
itself right those applications yourself
so where are we at with this so recently
a few months ago at the Consumer
Electronics Show we showed two demos two
demos that show you the possibilities
here first we implemented and connected
to the Google IOT platform implemented
mqtt very quickly through that java
engine took advantage of the twitter
client and we're able to send messages
back and forth very quickly to a card
printer and a thermal printer and third
we were able to take advantage of the
Google Maps client which will see a demo
on to be able to show location and
information directly on a card and on
the UI all of this coming from that that
Java based application engine so you can
think of think of the possibilities of
keeping that application layer separated
from that real time layer let us sweat
that make sure that we get that right
and enables others to develop solutions
we're real excited about our partnership
with micro edge and what I like to do
now is say thank you very much for the
opportunity to present zebra thermal
printers and micro edge and I'll
introduce Fred Rivard who is a CEO over
my courage he'll take you through the
demos as well as dig into some of the
details on this great solutions thank
you or Thank you Thank You Rico so I'm
going to go directly to a demo and so as
I'm booting the real device I will do a
virtual device demo so I'm going to
switch to my PC if adjusting can do that
okay so
so Victor mentioned that we have loaded
some kind of agents so when we started
for the demo for CS and for today
the idea was to pick up what's already
in the zebra straw in terms of
application just like on your Android
phone you have application you can
download so we downloaded the the adren
that connect to Google Cloud of course
with the mqtt we connected we downloaded
also the Twitter map
google map adjoins etcetera so all that
has been combined very easily on the on
the printer and here you can see a
virtual device so most as soon you have
some kind of virtualization a layer so
you can work using you know what you
have on your on your on your on your PC
desktop so you don't need all the 40
different product line internal printer
on your desk to be able to write an
application so let's go through a few of
them so obviously the very standard one
is to create a watch so it's a very
standard so you can of course download
any kind of watch on your on your
printer is the trial and let's let's go
on here let's say the Twitter agent so I
think that robot you're going to tweet
us from some live live tweets you just
did so let's let's go and see if we can
see a very last tweet of our robots
yes here so we can see the server server
let's say tweets live prints and so all
that in fact reflects some code that is
running on the virtual device and let's
now print and on the will charge by so
obviously the virtual device do not have
any printing agent so it will just show
up show show users the what's going to
be printed if it was a real printer and
we can now take a look at what's on the
let's say the connect the connected
analytics on Google ID so the when when
the printer has written some record he
also sent to the cloud that some data is
like the temperature of the printer held
and of course the last print the tweets
that have been done by by robots so
that's really live and so all that's in
fact allow people to design applications
very fast on the veteran device and I'm
gonna switch with a very the real device
now so that you can see it the same and
because a very same let's say binary
piece of code software is running on the
vettel device and on the live on the
vector on the real device there is no no
issue you will have the very same kind
of behavior I'm gonna switch to my
camera yeah so so the watch same watch
same watch on the both both both
printers and let's go to the Twitter app
so here you because the screen is very
small there's a way to select an
application is to scroll the application
than one by one so let's go to the so
Twitter so it's currently connecting to
a Twitter server and it's going to load
all the tweets and this one is from not
so for some reason it's not connected to
the one but anyway so I can then ask to
print that that that tweet and so
currently you can hear for so that's all
connected on the front row you can
probably understand and feel that song
the son of the printer so crowd is going
to be printed out and it will exactly
reflect what has been written on the
virtual device
so how long does it takes for one guy to
to do the CSD more roughly one engineer
3 weeks you know if you can see it right
and the tweet yeah so so basically we've
managed to have this printing engine
loaded with an image that has been
computed onboard life from a data that
has been sent over by the grab from from
the internet and the Google Cloud a
Twitter so so that's that's the demo we
just went through so basically some apps
that has been loaded and one very
important one is a GPL engine which is
how you connect to the underneath
underneath engine of the printer Vito
was mentioning so we have this Google
Cloud agent the second one on the right
and which in fact allow you to publish
and subscribe to any MQTT channel so it
means as soon you wrote that on your on
your device then you are connected
Google Cloud and that's it's done for
any hardware any any of those any let's
say it can OS underneath the behavior of
that piece of code that software will be
remains the same so you don't have to
retest recompile rebuild etc this one
you write this software agent once and
you can run and be deployed on any any
any device any printer so how does it
work so I've been asked to give you a
bit of sense of the technology so
obviously if you look at what has been
down on the Android for example when
Android came up we we had we were able
to phone
and let's say when as soon Android came
up five years later a 80% of the phone
were running Android and the kind of
marketplace for the apps were roughly 1
million apps so it means that if you are
able to let people write application on
any hardware because all this is a
smartphone of a very diverse very
various hardware cetera it means that
you can create a lot of value out of
this this concept of the tradition so
this is exactly what we've done at
markridge we've been able to to create a
small Chinese sibling of virtualization
that is used by Android and we targets
all the lines at all cost effective so
because in fact we had to read to reduce
the size of the size of the coin gene of
marriage of Android by 1,000 times
smaller so basically we target every
every processors that are below middle
12 to 15 dollars and the size of the
engine itself is roughly 30 K which is
very very very small
we can even say tiny so let's let's go a
bit or let's go and through the what
what we do most people tend to compare
earth to Android so that's how we there
is a position ourselves and in terms of
I would say what makes that happen so
one key message is that virtualization
is something that's in fact allow you to
decouple the hardware from the software
and so this is basically what has been
done reducing the size of needed let's
say layer to visualize a software
so yeah we have some kind of companion
and weight on one side and my crate on
other side to target all these devices
and something which is very important
for IOT creating a device connecting the
device to the cloud that's quite easy in
fact in something well known well
addressed by lots of let's say industry
but as soon you have a feat of device
lots of different various devices they
are not at all the same terms of
hardware in terms of software running on
it the OS is different the version of
the OS all that change along the time
and there is a need to be able to let's
say capture and create software assets
on top of that so this is a
virtualization that in fact we've been
able to downsize from 30 mega to let's
say 30 K in terms of size of the of the
footprint of the other filtration layer
so if you think as someone that is in
need to design a new device you will
have to find the right processor you
have read the roughly 1000 or 10,000
different processors compilers you have
roughly 4 to 5 compilers os's
same less than 10 etcetera if you
multiply all that the combination of all
that is what we call the matrix the
metrics of pain for the for the software
and it's this huge diversity is almost
impossible to to handle in a very
cost-effective way
so think about Android when they came up
just after for 5 years they they they
took all the markets of the smartphone
just because in fact when you have an
application you can be you can download
it on any any device and the next device
will be able to load the old application
etc so it means
- they come for lifecycle of the
software assets from the from the
hardware so we are pretty much similar
we provide the device maybe sandbox
application store the two main languages
of C and Java for that program of course
we support other languages but that's
the main the main two languages in terms
of markets we target probably the same
kind of market but only on the
cost-effective devices so wearables
medical devices energy meters medical
device lightning well and obviously
building automation home smart home etc
we roughly have 30 million devices
followed by micro age that has been sold
so far now and we partnered with with
Google to provide a very seamless way to
to connect and to have let's say the
plumbing the plumbing between the
devices and the cloud is something
that's shall not be lets say handled by
the developers especially if just think
about an evolution of the pram being the
of course there will be a v2 v3 v4 and
what about all the application running
on both sides so the plumbing needs to
be able to evolve without impacting in
fact the applications assets that has
been created by your ecosystems so
that's that's what we do with Google as
partner we provide the edge edge
computing side in terms of
virtualization and Google provides the
cloud part so Victor mentioned something
very very important security security
for lots of various devices so how do we
do and do we ensure that there is no way
for an application to go into the
printer engine and that's you can in
fact open your platform the printers to
an ecosystem of independent software
vendors so for them to create new apps
etc
so it means it needs to be very
bulletproof and there is a no no
confirmation on security so we do that
with sandboxes so we we use sandbox so
it's means that every application is in
fact into its own container and it
cannot escape and so one way to do that
is to reuse what has been used for smart
card in fact so we tend to use a read
kind of technology that solve in fact
for smart card so you can load an
application into a smart card same for
here but the application can't really
get out and so the the container the
sandbox controls the execution of the
application there are the grants if he
wants if it wants to to communicate with
underneath with the zebra crofting
activities so all that is completely
under control of the trusted execution
environment Mac reached Australia -
around we call that V for virtual
execution environment and so if these
institutional realm and allow the
printer to connect to Google Cloud then
the application will be the other
application will be able to talk to the
to the Google agent and then be able to
publish data to the to the cloud to get
analytics there is so all that is
something that is well-known from the
technical point of view but how do you
ensure that sandbox itself is protected
is a well design and there is no flow
and you can tweak it so that you can in
fact get into the underneath level the
core printing that you want to protect
so that's my technical slide in fact so
we have what we called binary code
inspection so we we are able to verify
before the application
is loaded or confined on a link to your
to your device that it does not have any
malicious code so we can do that by
doing huge analysis of the binary code
your software and if it doesn't fit the
semantics of the say of the sandbox of
the virtual execution environment then
it is not allowed to run and doing
thanks to that there is no way to to
overcome the trusted execution
environment and that has been proved in
the in the 20 to 28 20 years ago for the
smart cards so there is no way to from
the it says application itself to attack
the underneath system so think about a
system where the mass majority of
application or in fact control by this
trusted execution or it means that this
attackers the people's as wants to in
fact take into the controls of the
device do bad things with it the size of
the code that you need to be sure that
it says no burg no flow etcetera is
reduced to the many more so engine and
so that helps a lot in terms of having a
cost-effective device it means that you
you protect yourself from the attackers
you open the device to a large majority
of a large community and still you
protect your core engine that's the
purpose so virtual execution environment
of mark read as being runs through also
certification I've been exert if
occasion for those of you that know what
it is means that there's a probability
of work very very very low almost none
so combined with the binary check check
checking it's a very robust solution so
this is almost my last slide so
what we've been able to create with our
partner Google for zebra so there's a
zebra engineers they create printers
they know very well that job how to to
print that's something very hard as a as
victors explain it's a real-time and
gene timing is very needs to be very
accurate and so so in order to so that's
their call their core capabilities that
needs to be protected so to provide this
this this print these printers with an
printing engine on top of that you want
to have a community that creates
applications like a Twitter being able
to load a map being able to to create a
fancy card by adjusting maps addresses
crea code etc on the printer all that is
quite easy to do regular engineer can do
that in a few days so in order to give
them the possibility to do that you
create a virtual device and then you can
create your app on your on your on your
PC without even having a printer on your
desk obviously having all the printers
on your desk is a quite a challenge so
that's the rod the left the right part
so you have what we call an app
developer studio so that you can create
apps and then of course benefit from the
ecosystem with a strong where you can
load and store all the software assets
then underneath you have this trusted
executioner run on when you load all
these apps that you can download them
dynamically meaning that you have a new
protocol coming in you have your device
the printer or in the field since let's
say five years and you have a new new
protocols and you can download this new
protocol into its sandbox and still it's
going to be safe you don't need to
reassess all the all the other printer
and of course these are these agents on
the right sets allow you to communicate
we
is a Google cloud platform and you can
download that application that agent on
all all your printers it's going to be
the very same and imagine that Google is
changing is is a way to communicate with
them with a Google cloud platform
you just have to load the v-2 of that
guy and this is it
it's going to be available for all the
printers so there is no more protocol
issues you up future-proof your cost
effective because you write once an
application you can deploy it everywhere
in a very secure way and without
compromising there's a called the core
printing at the knowledge of of algebra
[Music]